I like to know that I can define my fame
and define my beauty for myself
if you are always changing what you do
based on what other people say
you completely lose yourself making it
is important but it's not more important
than keeping plans with your grandma and
your dad I put a lot of time and effort
into everything I do and to the point
that I did nothing else she's an
American singer-songwriter and actress
she's one of the best-selling musicians
of all time with over twenty-seven
million albums sold her achievements
include twelve Guinness World Records
and six Grammy Awards she's Lady gaga
and here's my take on her top ten rules
for success rule number one is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips also as Lady Gaga's
talking if she says something that's
really inspiring or meaningful to you
please leave it and write it down in the
comments below I put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired by the
message as well I just always felt
themes that's what my first album was
really about is that fame comes from
what is inside of you and it's not
something that you obtain and I still
feel that way a lot of ways I like to
know that I can define my fame and
define my beauty for myself which is why
I'm so vigilant and relentless about my
image and my music is I will not allow
no matter how successful I become for
the public to define or indicate what it
is I create or what it is that I believe
is beautiful or what I believe is a hit
pop record that's who I am and I will
always be that way relentless and
fearless and vicious and my own artist I
have my own vision
you
I suppose that there's one
interpretation of the female to sing a
love song and look pretty and just you
know I guess do what everyone thinks you
should do but it's just not what
inspires me and I'm inspired not just by
you know what I see in terms of the
future of music or tech or or fashion I
see also my fans and I think about what
they want to experience and they love to
feel out of touch with reality for a
moment so it might feel shocking maybe
but I really think it's just this sort
of surreal fantasy that I take pleasure
in creating for you someone asked me
once what they or many times I think
what I thought it meant to be an artist
and I said what I think an artist needs
essentially more than discipline or even
Talent is a perspective so if you are
always changing what you do based on
what other people say you completely
lose yourself and you become just you
know something that's constantly
affected by what's around you as opposed
to stable and your own and like
autonomous and your identity I've been
making music now with you know like Tony
Bennett for a couple years and I'm you
know Elton John is you know one of my
closest friends and his husband David
and they just have showed me that like
I'm a baby in my artistry you know and I
just have to keep making music and keep
going and so my focus really for this
album is showing that to to young girls
and to enta boys that want to make music
that you don't have to get lucky on the
internet it's not a social media game
you don't have to find a you know the
the the hot producer and get the hot
track you know to be a star you can just
learn how to play an instrument and sit
in your room and practice and write
songs and poetry and then you can go
around the corner to the bar and meet
other artists that do the same thing
that you do and you can hang out and
talk about music and
write songs and then you can play at the
spot around the corner and gain one fan
and then do it over and over and over
again until you're discovered for me you
know I did say in that skit that it is
the way to earn applause the other way
to earn applause is to earn it hard work
hard work and discipline and rehearsal
and that's always the most thrilling way
to earn applause and everything that
you've seen me do I've always rehearsed
a lot for it so it is um there's a lot
of passion that goes behind it
when she was 17 years old Stephanie got
her high school diploma and left the
nuns to join the prestigious Tisch
School of Arts a school entirely
dedicated to artistic disciplines
she took numerous classes such as arts
story music theater and dancing I was
really blessed and lucky to get in I got
in very early I was 17 and I was one of
20 people in in America that got into
the school early and I was really happy
and excited and I just felt like all my
dreams were coming true and it was a
wonderful school but it was very factory
like not in the Warhol factory like way
more like a sausage link factory where
everyone was taught the same sorts of
things and I think what I didn't like
about this school was I felt that they
wanted us all to be the same and possess
the same skills and I had something very
different inside of me her days at the
Tisch School of Arts were very busy her
evenings too Stephanie made her debut as
a singer in New York bars
holding
every night she would test out and adapt
her own compositions this experience
enabled her to find the secret to
writing good songs
Stephanie made one of the most important
decisions of her life she decided to
quit school and dedicate herself to
music what did you say your parents were
you like well my mother cried and my
father said you have one year and you
have to support yourself mm-hmm and I
said okay I do know for me it was never
I was never interested in anyone taking
care of me I mean I even had a job when
I was 15 years old because I liked to be
independent I like to do things on my
own terms so I left school and I got
like three different jobs and my dad
paid my rent for three months and then
when the three months was up I had to
pay and it was great it was wonderfully
liberating is it difficult now with the
pressure I would feel or think that
there would be pressure to continue to
outdo yourself or to continue to express
yourself there's always that pressure
but the best thing about it is it's only
a door away it's like you you know you
I've got the first album door it was
open it's great door stays open you work
I see I see it like a hallway my
creativity goes do I sound good no you
do not I say it's a hallway with wooden
doors the first door is open that's that
album you walk down there's another door
that's the next album and then there's
one more door and it's coming up right
and I'm banging on the walls and I'm
looking for hammers I'm trying to figure
out where the machine guns are looking
dry I just want to get to that freakin
door right right yeah but you know it's
there I know it's there but can I open
it hmm it's not the same as just writing
a song it's it's writing the next it's
writing the next chapter of whatever
lobe is in my brain is that's waiting to
paint Allah
and if people think I sound narcissistic
it's fine because you know Oprah it's
all I've got
it's my creativity yeah so I walk down
that hallway and it happened recently
the door open the door open it open it
blast open and once it opens the light
shoots right through and I'm in and then
I can relax because I know I broke
through the door so then you can is that
when the words flow the lyrics though
it's the words it's the everything it's
the it's the journey
got it it's the journey you know it's
the new journey of all of us and is
there something you can do to help the
creative process the doors open more
readily is there something you can do I
have a couple things that I do the
newest thing that I do I don't read a
damn thing no press no television no if
my mom calls and says did you hear about
I don't want to know nothing about
anything that is going on in relation to
music obviously I wouldn't know about
the world I shut it all off and I'm I'm
in it other than this interview Oprah I
do not intend to speak to anyone for a
very long time
this is my moment for me to experience a
rebirth with my own music I have to shut
it all out then no ways you know the
noise the noise it's loud you have to
cancel out the noise I remember that
your thoughts that matter you're so
smart you are very wise well I you are
well no that's how you do it that is how
you do you have to okay I just learned
how much more wise I am now and how much
I've learned and how important family is
and friendship and how your career and
and making it is important but it's not
more important than keeping plans with
your grandma and your dad you know
and and making sure that you you know
are on time you know for your mom's
event that she's doing whatever it is
that you're working on you know it's
it's that's what I've really learned
going into my you know the leaving my
20s is that it was time to have more
balance in my life how do I keep my ego
in check
I am always conscious of empowering
people around me I want everyone in my
team to know that they all play the same
equal part that I play and making
everything happen that happens every day
this is my family yeah my inspiration
I'm a loyal [ __ ] I make it a very
strong effort every second to be the
nicest person that I can be so let's
look at some of your headline making
outrageous outfits that you design tell
us about this one oh yeah
well that's Alexander McQueen and I
added the Hat dude it's an archive it's
the oldest archive in the mccune
collection and it was meant to be a
continuation of the VMA performance so
after I the princess had been murdered
by the paparazzi the the red lace was
meant to symbolize sort of my my eternal
martyrdom and this oh well that's you
know that's John Doe cast about that
bigger outfit and it I don't like to
wear fur so it was my way of making a
comment about fur
because it looks like a bunch of dead
Muppets budget like a bunch of dead
Muppets yeah absolutely
oh that's the Queen um well I I kind of
wanted to do an homage to the Queen yes
so that was my Queen Elizabeth the first
outfit but it's made out of latex oh it
still gotta go gaga so what did you
spend a lot of time thinking about it or
does it just come the the outfits the
the the creative expression the the
inspiration comes naturally but I put a
lot of time and effort into everything I
do and to the point that I do nothing
else I'm gonna wake up in the morning
and I work creatively all day and all
future things and I'm so what's a day
like you're thinking about I wake up in
the morning and I get on my computer and
I have files lists of references and I
have reference boards with all of my
materials on them and I basically call
the house of Gaga all day and argue with
them about what I want to do while they
tell me you can't do that I say yes I
can bleed to death on dressing
television
you know it's for me it's all about you
know being provocative is you're not
just about getting people's attention
it's about really saying something that
affects people and in a real way in a
positive way right so all the things
that I do in terms of the fame and in
terms of the fame monster it's it's
meant to sort of make it a bit easier to
swallow this this kind of horrific media
media world that we live in
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Virginia
Castillo asked me to so the famous
entrepreneur that you want me to
profound exit leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of the
rules had the biggest impact on you and
why what change are you going to make
what realization did you come to after
watching this video leave in the
comments I will join in the discussion
finally want to give a quick shout out
to Paul Bongard Paul thank you so much
for buying my book really means a lot to
me those are you watching you want a
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon
hey when she was little and you know
like kids when they're little alike I'm
gonna be a singer or I'm gonna be an
astronaut did you ever for one moment
believe that she would grow to be as big
as she is right now
and actually as a child she was very
childish to begin with okay
as a child she was very childish child
actually but she was very determined all
right and you know we could see it in
her you know when she was four no no she
would stand in front of the piano and
just bang on the keys and then she wrote
her first her first song it was I used
to play money by plank Pink Floyd right
right and she wrote her first song was
called dollar bill I love him up and
Cynthia my wife she still has it we
should we should have that yeah well you
know it was because you know on that
record they use they use actual money
and the cat you know the rat the
registered as instruments and I remember
as a kid I was so fascinated by that so
my dad played me a lot of you know great
music that made me like really fall in
love with the idea of making it my
greatest influence in this house for at
ten years was was Whitney yes and I used
to stand at the top of that staircase
and sing the star-spangled banner every
single day after school I my father and
I would I would play it over and over
and I would study her version of the
star-spangled banner and I used to stand
up there and I would study her and that
it's so interesting that you brought
that up mama it's like I don't forget
about it because I but I think to had
the Grammys when I won that award
because she for me is the greatest of
all time really the greatest of all time
to say thank you tonight
to Whitney Houston I wanted to thank
Whitney because when I wrote born this
way I imagined she was singing it
because I wasn't secure enough and
myself to imagine I was a superstar so
Whitney I imagined you were singing Born
This Way when I wrote it thank you
will you look under the rock we will you
search for tweets and will you search
for comments and see what people are
saying um well you know I like to stay
in contact with the fans and I want to
see how they're doing and enjoying the
music and pick up on their you know
little artistic nuances the things that
they create and that they say but um
I've just in a different place in my
life I don't allow like things that are
negative to run everything I think it's
important to just try to stay grounded
and who you are yeah and the things that
are good that come your way just be
grateful for them